do you ever fear like you know what if i
pay the price what if i do my part but
nobody finds out about it what if it
becomes like the best kept secret what
if i'm doing more than anybody else and
the other guy that makes all the excuses
or the other gal that's so lazy but they
get more recognition than i do why would
i pay the price
what if i promise you they will find you
but there's a price you got to pay by
the way
the right people that find you the
life's going to change your life's going
to change like this within 24 hours so
let me get right into my messaging if
this makes sense to you or shifts the
way you think give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel so
i remember i was coming up i'm 23 years
old 22 years old i'm busting my i'm
going back and forth to newport beach
from granada hills two and a half hours
with traffic and that's one way then
coming back and i'm going to conrad and
then i'm going to this other sales
office and i'm going to this other place
i'm working seven days a week i have no
life then it goes 22 23 24 i'm working
working working my guys are going to the
clubs i'm like dude i'm not coming to
the clubs what are you doing i'm reading
the stock book what
come to the clubs everybody's i'm not
coming i'm sitting there saying man am i
doing the right thing or not what the
hell am i doing at an apartment complex
reading a business book what am i doing
is this even gonna work a guy my boss at
bali's jose said these business books
don't work if they did more people would
be rich they just the only people that
make money off these business books are
the authors you're not going to make
money off these business books i'm like
this guy's supposed to be my mentor i'm
like this level he's here maybe he's
right so i said i'm not going to believe
all this stuff i'm going to pay the
price i'm going to go
so i start working but every time i'm
working i'm like man i wish if people
knew how much how much how hard i was
working i'd get more respect than i'm
getting today on pat but be patient one
more month two more months a year
year later i'm getting results people
are like wow you didn't get lucky
getting these results you're doing
something but nothing on a big scale now
the year goes by 26 now i get attention
hey this guy's up to something i don't
know what it is but he's
up to something another year goes by 27.
i speak in front like 7 000 people and i
get invited then next thing you know
ward got out this guy's running won the
best sales offices across the country
then people around the world canada all
across the country are coming to our
sales office
in granada hills and northridge to find
out why the hell is two 300 people
coming to the sales office every single
flipping week what the hell is going on
they would come for two days and they
would watch it from early in the morning
till late or night how come people don't
leave at midnight how come people are
coming early at eight o'clock what the
hell is going on they're fighting
they're competing they're laughing
they're pulling pranks they're joking
they're making calls
it's loud there's music playing what's
going on here then word got out in 2009
2010 and then fast forward the rest is
history right with the business why am i
sharing the story with you eventually
somebody found me eventually a man found
me and said i want to introduce you to
the right people and he took me boom
boom boom boom boom eventually those
people learn how to use me
by telling my story to others who said
wow this guy's up to something
eventually at 29 years old a guy came up
to me in california who were one of
these guys that lift up the next
governors that have aspirations of being
governors but they find him early we had
a meeting at this man's house very well
connected you probably know this man's
name so he's helped a lot of different
people become say hey do you have any
plans i'm like not at all well if you do
here's what the format will be we would
like to get a team around you i'm like
how did these people show up out of
nowhere then i'm getting invited to
weird dinners then i'm getting invited
to dinners with prince edward with pres
with all these random people showing up
how did this happen
because i did my part and i trusted the
fact that if i do my part behind closed
doors the right people will eventually
show up out of nowhere and make the
introduction to the people that you need
to be introduced to and then like this
everything changes justin bieber usher
found him eminem dre found him 50 cent m
pamela anderson canadian football league
she's on the big screen they found her
boom they watched the rest is history do
you know how many people liking
political people boom somebody hears
obama giving a speech in chicago at a
small setting with 30 40 people like wow
who is this guy why is he speaking this
way a ronald reagan is working at ge
starts going around the country talking
about how great america is then they say
this guy could be one day the president
united states maybe this guy's going to
be
it doesn't matter what business you're
in what you're doing
if you pay the price behind closed doors
the right people will find you but
here's what i can tell you for me today
is september 10th today makes it 20
years i've been in the financial
industry i got started a day before 9 11
and i've been in the same business 20
years most people will go boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom and that's
why nobody ever finds you because the
moment something gets hard you go to the
next thing the moment something gets
already go to the next thing the moment
something goes
it's real estate is not good for me
observing them oh it's not insurance
when i go okay oh it's on your phone
you can only say that a couple times
eventually it ain't the industry it's
you so for some of you guys that want
that kind of respect you want people to
find you well maybe you ought to show
the level of commitment
of focusing on one thing so much until
you become one of the best where the
world comes to you and says this person
is worthy of being found we got to tell
this person's story her story's got to
be told his story's got to be told and
then the rest is history so like i asked
you earlier
if this message made sense to all of you
who behind closers are paying the price
but nobody sees you it sees you and give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel and if
you've never seen a video i did on work
ethic the benefits of work ethic if
you've never seen it click over here to
watch that video take care everybody bye
[Music]